les humiliations des violences physiques
et psychiques les témoignages de détenus
de la base américaine de guantanamo
rapportés par amnesty international
lesquels à boussens peu plus le deuxième
mandat de george bush déjà entachée par
plusieurs affaires de torture
ce rapport est publié au 4ème
anniversaire de la première
incarcération d'un terroristes présumés
à guantanamo
magali fera t il derrière ces portes le
tribunal militaire d'exception de
guantanamo où depuis hier l'un des neuf
inculpés du camp et entendu l'accusé un
yéménite qui s'était réclamé d'al-qaïda
l'an dernier refuse le défenseur
militaires commis d'office
l'avocat lui même admet le droit de son
client à se défendre au sol dénonce une
procédure entièrement illégitime
monsieur bahlul n'a pas affaire à un
vrai juge ni un jury de ses pairs et les
règles changent tous les jours déclare
t-il à la presse d audience qui coïncide
avec la quatrième année de détention à
guantanamo de prisonniers soupçonnés de
terrorisme après la guerre d'afghanistan
sur les quelques 500 islamistes détenus
arbitrairement aucun n'a été jugé à ce
jour aucune visite seul le comité
international de la croix rouge a pu se
rendre sur place
les images de prison modèle distillé par
washington
une opacité qui en dit long sur les
conditions de détention des prisonniers
sans statut et sans garanties
judiciaires
amnesty international vient de publier
un nouveau rapport accablant
ce rapport souligne la gravité de la
situation nous la connaissions déjà mais
elle confirme et amplifie les
inquiétudes que nous avions notamment
sur des pratiques de torture de
traitements cruels inhumains et
dégradants et de mauvais traitements
guantanamo ces trois nouveaux
témoignages que nous publions montre à
quel point ces actes de torture sont
fréquents et d'une très grande gravité
pour la santé physique mais aussi
mentale des détenus 167 témoignage
recueilli à ce jour d'anciens détenus de
guantanamo comme celui de ce marocain
tous parlent de violence d'humiliation
sexuelle de profanation du coran à
l'interrogatoire
disait qui fait
n'avait aucun droit et que personne que
vous aider disait que même que même dieu
ne peux pas vous aider
quinze mille suspect serait actuellement
détenu par les américains à travers le
monde dans des prisons hors la loi au
nom de la lutte antiterroriste des
méthodes de plus en plus critiquée y
compris par les alliés des etats unis
attention